ich möchte einmal wieder über Corona
sprechen und zwar hat Jens Spanier etwas
ganz fantastisches verkündet er will die
epidemische Lage von nationaler
Tragweite auslaufen lassen er selbst hat
das zwar gar nicht zu entscheiden das
macht der Bundestag auch ganz ohne Jens
Spahn aber PR-technisch ist das
natürlich ganz toll für ein
Gesundheitsminister der anderthalb Jahre
lang wirklich im absoluten knallert
Modus regiert hat jetzt auch mal was
positives zu verkünden aber man muss
sich doch die Frage stellen warum haben
wir ein epidemische Lage warum haben wir
überhaupt einen corona-ausnahmezustand
wir haben gerade ein total entspannten
Sommer hinter uns man kann sich die
Todeszahlen die inzidenzzahlen die
Krankenhauseinweisung anschauen da war
wirklich nicht so viel los zumindest
nicht so viel dass es auch nur
ansatzweise ein
corona-ausnahmezustand rechtfertigt
hätte und daraus lernt man dass die
Regierung sich diese Rechtsgrundlage
geschaffen hat obwohl sie sie überhaupt
nicht braucht eigentlich sollte man auf
Krisen ja reagieren wenn sie wirklich da
sind und sich nicht mal präventiv
irgendwelche Sonderrechte herausnehmen
und ja einfach mal schauen was dann
kommt auch wenn erstmal überhaupt nichts
kommt und das ist für mich die große
Lehre aus der corona-pandemie der Staat
hat sich Corona macht gesichert und will
sie auch nicht abgeben und das macht mir
leider wirklich Sorge
Philipp das ist sicherlich ein Punkt der
der heute sehr sehr wichtig war und was
steht denn in diesem infektionsgesetz
Schutzgesetz drin das ist das eine
eine epidemische Lage vorträgt von
nationaler Tragweite vor Dich wenn eine
ernsthafte quer für die öffentliche
Gesundheit besteht und du sagst das war
nicht der Fall ich finde das war schon
der Fall wenn wir sehen welche Folgen
Corona hatte auch in den
Intensivstationen in den letzten welche
hatte ist waren natürlich viele viele
Menschen auf den Intensivstationen das
haben wir die Statistiken haben wir
gesehen dass wenn viele Menschen
gestorben wir werden bald eine runde
Zahlen haben von Verstorbenen auch in
Deutschland also insofern haben viele
Menschen sind verstorben ältere war
nicht geimpft 70 80-Jährige sind
gestorben an Corona ich kenne selbst
wirklich viele
Angehörige und das kann man auch nicht
in negieren der schubiles sollten wir
hier auch nicht tun egal insofern
die zählen würde mich auch 70 80-Jährige
zehn für mich zur Allgemeinheit und
viele sind gestorben doch das ist schon
die Frage und sind gestorben und Jens
Spahn hat darauf hingewiesen dass er
glaubt Teil der Einfassung Einschätzung
nicht dass man das jetzt beenden kann
und diese drei Monatsfrist auslaufen
lassen kann du hast recht Philipp es
sind nicht es nicht der der Minister der
dafür zuständig ist sondern ist der
Bundestag der sowas alle drei Monate
entscheiden muss und es sind die
Gesundheitsminister der Länder die diese
Entscheidung dann auch umsetzen müssen
und eigentlich auch gemeinschaftlich
umsetzen müssen aber ein Minister und
das finde ich gut an Jens Spahn muss
natürlich ein Zeichen setzen und
vorangehen insofern finde ich es ein
wichtiges Signal von ihm zu sagen also
ich finde die Lage hat sich verändert
tut etwas damit jemand der solches
Gewicht hat der bringt schon etwas voran
in dieser Frage Herr Bosbach wie sehen
Sie das denn hatte Deutschland im Sommer
ein corona-ausnahmezustand der das
gerechtfertigt hat dass wir so lange in
der epidemischen Lage waren nein
Oberziel war ja immer keine Überlastung
unseres Gesundheitssystems und jeder der
an coronaco wird 19 erkrankt soll die
notwendige medizinische Behandlung
bekommen einschließlich
intensivmedizinischer Behandlung
einschließlich künstliche Beamten da war
nie eine Überlastung unseres
Gesundheitssystems aber wir hatten eine
fragile Lage und wenn man nicht
abschätzen konnte wie werden sich im
Herbst die Zahlen entwickeln nicht nur
Infektion sondern auch schwere Verläufe
hat man für drei Monate diese
epidemische Lage von nationaler
Tragweite beschlossen und würde ich
jeden Satz unterschreiben den Herrn
Anderter gesagt hat ich habe nur eine
andere Sorge nämlich dass wir uns
langsam daran gewöhnen dass der
begründungspflichtig ist der seine
Freiheitsrechte in Anspruch nehmen
möchte der Regelfall muss genau
umgekehrt sein der Staat muss begründen
warum er in die Freiheitsrechte
das ist aktuell noch richtig ist dass
wir beispielsweise Maske tragen müssen
dass ich war jetzt zum Beispiel das
Wochenende in Holland und da ist es
jetzt zum Beispiel schon weg Österreich
auch was ich am schlimmsten finde Herr
Borsbach muss ich sagen ich bin am
schlimmsten persönlich es wurde nie
unterbrochen also der der Zustand wurde
ja nie unterbrochen zum Beispiel in
Österreich wo die Maske mal
zurückgenommen aber ich finde es
wirklich verteilt Deutschland hat es
einfach nie unterbrochen aber es waren
ja nicht immer dieselben Zahlen und
dieselben Kurven also wie kann es denn
sein dass wir nie auch meine Lockerungen
gemacht haben weil der überwiegende Teil
der Bevölkerung nicht nur dafür war
sondern sich auch strengere Regeln hat
vorstellen können und das ist richtig
wir haben Gürtel und Hosenträger
genommen safety first es gibt andere
Dinge die haben mich mehr aufgeregt im
Flugzeug herrscht ein strenges Regiment
und anschließend stehst du im
Flughafenbus Nase an Nase eine
Viertelstunde da sagt kein Mensch was ja
das ist es gibt viele Kuriositäten aber
jetzt wird es Zeit weil wir auch sehen
dass die schweren Verläufe weniger
werden uns auf den Schutz derjenigen zu
konzentrieren die in besonderer Weise
gefährdet sind deswegen ja auch die
Nachimpfungen von Eltern die Status
gewesen sich auf die zu konzentrieren
finde ich auch wirklich das haben wir
also das haben wir nicht in der
Intensität getan vor einem Jahr wie wir
es hätte tun müssen
wir damals zum Beispiel sehr gut man
wollte den Lockdown für alle anstatt die
zu schützen die es wirklich nötig hatten
jene die das gefordert haben übrigens
die gesagt haben wie Hendrik streek auch
wie Christian Lindner z.B die gesagt
haben wir müssen jetzt die Altenheim
schützen da sterben über 50 Prozent der
Menschen also 50% aller Kroner Toten
kommen aus Altenheimen da die
Bundeskanzlerin gesagt nein nein man
kann nicht Millionen von Menschen
wegsperren aber da ging es gar nicht
darum es ging darum vor Heim zu testen
wir haben aber viele isoliert und an die
Risiken und Nebenwirkungen hat man dabei
nicht gedacht selbst bei Mama erlebt in
der Zeit zweimal im Krankenhaus kein
Besuch gar nichts ja das war schlimm
aber wir können jetzt alle damit meine
ich gar nicht sie aber hier schlau daher
reden wir haben so etwas auch noch nie
erlebt also eine solche Pandemie eine
weltweite Pandemie mit einer Ausdrücke
von einem Erreger den keiner kannte wo
es doch unterschiedlichste Vorstellung
gab am Anfang sollten wir doch noch
nicht mal Maske tragen so hieß es
immer sagen
naja wir wussten nicht das dauert eine
Zeit bis man erstmal gefunden gewusst
hat wo kommt diese Erreger her was
sprechen ja nicht über die Fehler der
ersten Wochen wir sprechen ja darüber
was im letzten Jahr passiert ist also
als man schon sechs Monate Corona
Erfahrung hatten erstens und zweitens
haben andere Länder es ja anders gemacht
auch mit Wissen und mit Überzeugung und
wenn man sich mal die inzidenzzahlen
aber auch die die Todeszahlen anschaut
Deutschland und Schweden die letzten 12
Monate das eine Land 6 Monate im
Lockdown das andere Land komplett ohne
dann verlaufen diese Kurven komplett
parallel da lese ich auch
unterschiedliche Stellungnahmen darüber
tatsächlich ich habe im im Sommer habe
ich ganz unterschiedliche Dinge darüber
gelesen dass Schweden das Modell nämlich
überhaupt nicht funktioniert und das
Modell voll gegen die Wand gefahren ist
also das stimmt eins von beiden kann ja
nur stimmen aber ja aber in dem irgendwo
für alle ein Impfstoff heraus weil sie
uns gesagt für alle ein Impfstoff zur
Verfügung stand da hätte doch der Staat
die Verantwortung zurückgeben müssen
jetzt kannst du dich impfen nun sie zu
was hat denn der Staat ja auch
angekündigt im März angekündigt und das
Versprechen einfach gebraucht weil in
dem Moment wo Sie sich schützen können
sind sie für sich selbst verantwortlich
sie sagen ja auch ich rauche oder ich
rauche nicht man ist für andere
verantwortlich naja
das ist ja richtig man kann sich dann
und und in dem Moment muss man es doch
als Übergriff des Staates empfinden wenn
er den Lockdown beibehält oder die
ganzen Ausläufer mit denen wir es jetzt
zu tun haben die Masken wenn dafür keine
Grundlage mehr besteht wir dürfen ja
nicht vergessen es gab ja wir reden
jetzt den über Corona Wasser und über
die Toten und über die Erkrankten wir
reden nicht über die psychologischen
Folgen das heißt wir halten immer es ist
immer was passiert wäre Grone auch
während der Maßnahmen wir haben einen
Preis gezahlt und zwar haben wir den
auch auf dem Rücken der Kinder gezahlt
als war jetzt nicht wir machen einen
Lockdown allen geht super toll wir haben
keine psychologischen Folgen und es ist
super klasse für alle Menschen wir
schützen sondern wir haben auch
geschadet und da hätte auch ich mir als
Bürgerin von der Kanzlerin auch manchmal
eine Abwägung mehr gewünscht ich finde
wir Deutschen sind freiheitsvoll
geworden und haben uns also ich finde
wir können uns bei den Kindern bei
heranwachsen später mal wirklich
entschuldigen tja und das ist genau
genau der Punkt man wusste am Anfang
vielleicht nicht wie Schulen wie Kinder
betroffen sind man wusste dass dann aber
im Sommer 2020 und andere Länder haben
wir reagiert die Schweiz beispielsweise
hat nach dem ersten Lockdown gesagt
alles klar wir machen die Schulen nie
wieder zu und hat sie auch offen
gelassen und das hat bestens
funktioniert ganz viele Länder ähnlich
und kein Land hat so lange die Schulen
dicht gelassen bedeutet und dafür die
hat die Kanzlerin sich eingesetzt sie
hat die mpks unterbrochen um Druck
aufzubauen auf die Ministerpräsidenten
mit dem einzigen Zweck die Schulen
zuzumachen sie hat nichts dafür getan um
sie zu öffnen wir hatten ja
unterschiedliche Regelungen in den
Bundesländern und wir hatten tatsächlich
das ist so Ausrede kann historisches
Vorbild es wurde immer rekoriert auf die
Spanische Grippe von vor 100 Jahren und
wir erleben dass wir ganz
unterschiedliche Verläufe und
Infektionsketten haben selbst im
Bundesgebiet ich empfehle mal nonce und
South Dakota von den südökonomischen
Daten vergleichbar zwei Nachbarländer in
den in den USA zwei ganz
unterschiedliche Wege aber die Verläufe
waren gar nicht so unterschiedlich das
heißt man hat auch während der Pandemie
viel gelernt aber im Moment sind wir
dabei die diese Kritik teilig und Mensch
sind wir dabei die Vorsicht zu sehr zu
betonen vor der Freiheit obwohl wir
mittlerweile Impfquote haben von 65 70
ich glaube über 80 Prozent oder ja nur
ich will mal sagen also das ist ja alles
schön wenn wir hier alle überzeugt sind
uns kann gar nichts mehr passieren ich
lese aber andere Dinge ich gucke mir die
Statistik an ich sehe Bayern die ganzen
Grenzgebiete das sind wir Inzidenzen zum
Teil von
100-200 und das ist wieder so wie den
härtesten Zeiten ich lese immer mehr von
angeblichen Kampf Durchbrüchen muss mir
nur jemand erklären gibt es die oder
gibt es die nicht doppelt geimpft
trotzdem Corona Intensivstation was
passiert mit denen ich lese immer mehr
von jungen Menschen die jetzt auf in den
Krankenhäusern legen gibt es die gibt es
die nicht wir tun jetzt alle so als wäre
Corona vorbei und ich lese auch das
Corona und Steve verlassen wir können
das waren jetzt diese Fragen wie einfach
jetzt mal zu Hause diskutieren wir haben
jetzt eine kleine mini-unterbrechung zum
Beispiel können sie mal den RKI Wert
diskutieren zu Hause ob du eigentlich
jemand sinnvoll war oder nicht und wir
sind gleich wieder zurück genau
[Musik]